yes, I'm taking a break after the game
so I don't end this with a game
group I don't even know
what he's playing it's okay
with my
side variation, it's a little annoying for you,
hopefully
the way of playing definitely has the
advantage
that you  here no longer quickly
checkmate is usually
sorry
so disadvantage is it is a bit
slow he
five I should have paid attention to it
he makes something interesting right away
yes is what is that
next makes a stupid impression ne
maybe you can just go
back
the whole thing  yes also my weakness
is there on the intestinal wing
so yes
first B4 prevents
so
yes good that really threatens does
not do that yet there on C5
now the games for example
yes where from that can of course still
do I thought so that she
is two pregnant here from the jumper the  five
because then I have such a skewer here on C5
maybe it will still work
with the maybe compensation no
somehow
yes I still have to play what should
I do
so that prepares
what is now with A4 in the position
then the C5 can probably
really take it
what is Tom F D1
with the idea bishop C5 or worse
B5
probably doesn't work well
if I play A4
maybe A4
bishop C5
that's still gotten complicated
or I play knight E2
let's do two
so he probably wants to go here
if I have to  now let's see if I can get him
properly supported
so he prevented
that's kind of difficult
so the stuff is now at least
halfway secured here
question is
you can do something active sometimes
so the idea of ​​the move is maybe
pull knight A5
if  he lets me
yes okay
now Springer A5
he will of course get
rolling no but come in
little time have to
do something here so
can take like here no that’s why
I couldn’t take five
yes I thought to myself just such
a stupid one  Move could also go,
so maybe Herr is now threatening to
take here because A5 is hanging,
it looks very shaky and I
only have one minute left, well
C5 is catching now,
well, he still has a weakness
on e5,
I can still do it with it  what to do
is it really clear here the
position knows
already very ambitious ne
G3
so
just wants to prevent him then also
blocking me so and now
taken dirt directly here great
so you five yes
now he can also take G2 we
have  yes okay keeping it broken is
lost
unfortunately unfortunately
maybe you have to
look for alternatives early on I got
up here relatively quickly well
maybe you have to do A4 now
that would have prevented a lot of problems I
think I
think he has to pull B4 and then
jump now  two and then
I don't have these wobbling problems because on the
intestinal wing
somehow it was a
bit stupid here
and now yes now maybe now
again A4 probably
then you think I'm still
quite good even
stupid I don't have I don't have
after that the
position is complete if I have to play A4
but probably play B4 and
then I can I can
reinforce myself normally again ne knight C1 B3 yes yes
two stupid I have to play A4 myself
the mood is then I think even
quite good
yes  Pity